wow i did not expect so many little
differences and changes
that are making the xps so incredible
hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new dell xps 13
9310 and today we're gonna be comparing
against
apple's latest and greatest 2020 13-inch
macbook pro
the specs between these two are
basically identical other than one key
difference now i'm gonna have links to
both these down in the video description
below
there's a fantastic price right now on
the macbook pro let's go ahead and get
this open delos upgraded
their packaging but weirdly they can't
seem to glue this
straight to make it look nice and let's
pull this off we got this nice little
briefcase style
opening up there we go and today we're
not only going to be comparing
the specs we're also going to take a
deep dive into the keyboards the track
pads the displays
the brightness and reflectivity the fan
noise
the thermal performance we're gonna look
at graphics
and i'm particularly excited because
this new xps is one of the first laptops
with intel's 11th generation
processors with the intel xe graphics
let's start out with the exterior
differences and even though the xps has
a slightly larger display it's a 13.4
inch
compared to 13.3 you guys can see that
the macbook pro
is longer and deeper as far as the size
so the dell is nice and compact
now as far as thickness they are very
close
if we're measuring by the fronts they
are identical but if we measure
the backs where the hinges are the xps
is slightly thicker
but its feet do stick out a little bit
more and as far as build quality and
finishes both are excellent dallas
really stepped it up in the last year
and a half
it's made out of a lot more aluminum
pretty much all aluminum the hinge is
aluminum now
the build quality is nice and then if we
take a look at the bottoms both are very
clean
and i like the dell just like apple now
curves the side of the
laptop that means that these vents and
ports right here aren't
blocked by a blanket anymore like they
used to but they still have this bottom
vent
that can get blocked if it's on your lap
and now let's talk about
ports both these laptops have ports on
either side the macbook pro at least
this higher spec model
has four thunderbolt 3 ports whereas the
xps has
one port on each side we also have
headphone jacks on both and xps
offers us a micro sd card slot which is
really nice for those photographers out
there people that shoot drones or just
want a little bit extra
storage now there is one difference that
the ports on the xps 13 this brand new
one
are now thunderbolt 4 ports and that's
paired with that 11 gen
processor and the maximum bandwidth is
the same there's just a lot less
limitations on thunderbolt 4.
if you want to know more and all the
details about how these compare we'll
have a link in the video description
now let's go ahead and open these up the
macbook pro can open with one hand which
is nice
the dell unfortunately doesn't have that
same cutout which is one thing that we
wish they would update
and it's going to be a no-go all right
so we're going to use two-handed method
there we go let's go ahead and get these
turned on
and both of these do have touch id or
fingerprint sensors in the power button
which is nice
and as this is turning on let's talk
about the layouts now right away you can
see the dell xps is quite a bit smaller
than the 13 inch macbook pro now we do
have this nice
soft touch carbon finish i really like
it it doesn't get as cold as the macbook
pros
it's nice and soft but there are a
couple downsides one it doesn't feel as
premium as the full aluminum design and
two it does pick up fingerprints
really easily a standout feature of the
macbook
is the touch bar some people like it
some people don't like it
i just use it for the standard things to
use the shortcuts keys for
really do i really need it and a
standout with xps
is facial recognition with windows hello
now i
absolutely love this and let's tilt this
right here
it's going to recognize my face and it's
kind of like face id
on an iphone or an ipad it works really
great
you open up your laptop and bam it logs
you in
almost instantly now a lot of you guys
always point out that you can use your
apple watch to unlock your mac
and yes that does work but i hope apple
adds in
face id to their macs in the future and
now let's compare the keyboards and i
have to say
that dell has been doing a great job and
i can't type and talk at the same time
but these keys feel excellent i don't
want to say that they feel better than
apple's
magic keyboard that just got updated as
well
but maybe they might these remind me of
the hush keys
that google has been putting out that
you get a nice tactile
feedback but they're also have a little
bit of softness to them not in a bad way
and they're quiet
whereas apples they're a little bit
louder they give you a little bit more
feedback but i don't know they're both
excellent nobody's gonna have any issues
with them and
i have my two on one the previous xps
and this keyboard is good but listen how
much louder that is
and the same thing goes for the track
pad you guys hear that clickiness and
both of these we gave
really good reviews to you hear the new
xps
much much quieter and it feels great now
the trackpad design
is a diving board design meaning it's
harder at the top instead of the bottom
but it almost feels like it's not it
only gets really tough at the very top
but down just a little bit it feels
excellent so they've definitely made
this nicer and then the macbooks well
it's a lot larger
and it has that magnetic force touch
design
it definitely is a step above but once
again nobody's going to complain about
the xps
and now let's do our webcam microphone
and speaker comparison we're going to
start out with the speakers go ahead and
put on
your best pair of headphones and let's
take a listen
let me know what you thought down in the
comment section below of course we're
recording through a microphone it's
going through youtube so i'll give you
guys my opinions
the macbook pro sounds a lot better it
has
actual deep bass that you can hear
instead of kind of some a little bit of
popping that's kind of more in the mids
midst
the whole sound is richer it's cleaner
now the xps is
louder and the high frequencies the
tweeters are very sharp and very loud
but the sound quality
isn't there still i'm still glad that it
gets that loud a lot of previous dell
xps
couple years ago were very very quiet so
they definitely stepped up in that
department
now let's compare the webcams and the
microphones this is the microphone and
webcam quality from the 2020
13 inch macbook pro and this is the
webcam and microphone
quality from the 2020 dell xps 13.
let me know which one looks better and
which one sounds better down in the
comments section below
and now let's go ahead and compare the
displays now
first thing that really comes up is the
size of the bezels the macro pro
bezels they're not huge but when you put
it against the 13 inch xps they do look
pretty massive
i love that dell is maximizing this
chassis they even got rid of the dell
logo down here so that you can have a
larger screen that's also
16 by 10 just like the macbook pro i
love that
and as far as the sharpness or detail
both look excellent but the dell
definitely has the macbook b
out it has 9.2 million pixels so we're
actually slightly higher than
4k on this sim computer instead of right
in between 1080p and 4k
with the macbook we have 4 million
pixels so more than double the pixels on
the xps
now with the dell you have multiple
options for the displays
you can get a 1080p display rs is that
4k
or more than 4k and it's also a
touchscreen which you cannot get
on the macbook pro and with the macbook
all the displays are
identical now as far as brightness i
went ahead and maxed out both of these
and they look
very similar at least from the standard
usage
angle they're both at 500 nits which is
awesome i'm glad dell stepped up their
displays
really nice to look out in brighter
environments now off
axis vadim's camera angle he's saying
that the dell actually looks
better than the macbook pro now there's
two ways that the macbook display
actually beats out the xps but before
that i do want to mention
that i could definitely tell that the 4k
display is
sharper especially with text it's not a
massive difference
but it's there and with that you
actually do lose battery life and we're
going to talk about battery life in just
a bit
the first way the macro pro display is
better is color accuracy now i have to
say this is
very interesting if you guys see right
here on both of these we're seeing that
logo inside of the box now in the
previous xps's
you couldn't because they would not
display p3 white colors there'd just be
one you know red color here i just
double checked and yes
dell did update this display that is
wonderful
news now the macbook pros is still
better with color accuracy and
it does almost 100 p3 compared 90 but
that's still an
excellent improvement the second way is
display reflectivity
now the macro pro has deeper blacks it
is less reflective
but the difference is actually pretty
small and i'm really surprised
and i just compared it to this two on
one which has the same exact
over 4k panel 500 nits it's a lot more
reflective than the new xps 13. so dell
has improved their coatings
and now it's much much closer to the
macbook pro to a point where i would say
it probably doesn't matter now yes
the blacks are a little bit more gray
but with that 500 nits it's going to do
a great job
outdoors in the sun and now finally
let's get into performance we're going
to start out with
the ssds i have aja open here because
it's cross
platform let's go ahead and hit start
and both of these have 512 gigabyte nvme
ssds
and it looks like the dell is faster
we're looking at 2536
for right so about 200 faster and as far
as read it's about
two to three hundred megabyte per second
faster as well so not only is the xps
faster
but you can actually upgrade the ssd
yourself so later down the line you want
to throw a one terabyte or a two
terabyte in
you could do so for not very much money
and with a matter of maybe five ten
minutes you'll be upgrading which you
can't do with the macbook pro
now let's compare the processor
performance using geekbench five both of
these have i5 quad-core processors
but we're comparing tension to the brand
new 11 chan both these have
low power ddr4 but the xps is runs
faster at about
4200 instead of about 3700 so we'll see
how that plays into this test let's go
ahead and hit run
and as this is running let me tell you
that both of these are equipped with 16
gigabytes of ram
so no difference there but there is a
difference in base
frequency this one's at 2 gigahertz
compared to 2.4 so it looks like 11 gen
really kind of kicked up that base clock
and
wow that is an impressive result for the
xps i don't think i've ever seen
a single core score this high
and on the macbook side we're looking at
instead of 1401 which is amazing
1098 now this is a little bit lower than
we typically get we're typically at
about a hundred or so higher than that
about 1200
so uh this score right here for single
core that's a 28
difference that's massive and typically
we're on big sur right now it typically
be roughly 20
difference which is still huge now as
far as the multi-core
it's still a big difference we have
53.50 compared to 4261
which is already a great score and
that's also actually slightly higher
than 20
difference in performance so it looks
like the new chips in here
with that faster ram it's making a
pretty significant difference and this
xps
is going to be a screamer i also want to
mention that this actually ran
quieter towards the end of the test
where it's multi-threaded
than the macbook pro but we're going to
take a look at fans and thermals here in
just a second
and next let's compare the graphics now
our macbook pro has the g7
graphics the best available for the 10th
generation
but the new xps 11 gen has intel iris
xe graphics i know if that stands for
extreme
or something else but let's run this
test using opencl
wow that finished so much faster i don't
know the score yet because it's being
blocked by this
let's wait for the macbook to catch up
all right we have 8408 for the opencl
which is our typical score
and 14 881.
so that is about 80 percent faster
graphics
with this new intel 11gen xe it's
very impressive now i do have to mention
that with the macbook pro using mac os
most applications are now using metal so
i did run the metal test as well
we got 97.08 so we got a higher score
there
and even with that the xps is still
roughly 50
faster in terms of graphics performance
now before we go into unigine heaven
and test out the gaming performance i
also want to mention something else that
comes with these 11gen and the xps
and that's wi-fi 6 and bluetooth 5.1
which you don't get on the macbook pro
now as far as bluetooth 5.1 isn't a big
deal
you are going to get a little bit better
range a little bit better reliability
but the wi-fi 6
part that matters so i have good
internet at home i have a wi-fi 6 router
and at the toughest basement corner of
my house i would actually get about
twice the speed
with the previous xps that also had
wi-fi six so instead of getting about 90
i would get about 170 megabit per second
so
keep that in mind if that matters for
you now unfortunately the macbook with
big sur
is not launching unigine heaven but
we're still going to run it to test out
how the new xe graphics perform and i do
have our previous test
with the older version of the xps 10 gen
open and the macbook pro so you can
still compare
the scores we're almost done with the
test and i want to point out that it
seems like this new xps
is running quieter than the previous one
even though we have more powerful
graphics
there we have it and wow once again man
the graphics are
killing it we're looking at 24.4
fps for integrated graphics and this is
by far the best i've ever seen
even beating out some low end cards that
people put into
laptops now just a year and a half maybe
two years ago
this was like at seven or eight massive
improvements so
compared to the previous xps that got
13.7 and this macbook pro
when it's working it runs at 13.5 so
almost the same
about four months ago but with this
update almost twice the graphics
performance which is great
for gaming video editing things like
that now i want to put in a plug here
if you guys want to see how this 11th
gen compares to the 10
gen which i have where's my other laptop
right here
same exact version that's in the macbook
pro if you guys want to see some
maybe video editing photo editing some
gaming tests make sure you guys click
that subscribe button and enable those
notifications
and now it's time to test the full
performance of the processors
as well as taking a look at the heat and
the fan noise now i've seen a bench r20
open here
it's going to push all the cores to
their limits unfortunately on the window
side for some reason
intel power gadget is not working so i
have a couple alternatives so we'll
still be able to make this
work let's go ahead and get started with
our test i'm going to hit
run on both of these and i'm going to
keep an eye out on our
wattage and our frequencies and then
temperatures as well
right away we're at 90 degrees on the
dell and
98 on the macbook pro even hotter and we
reached a peak of almost
40 watts on the macbook and we're
looking about 36.38
on the xps so it also is going above
that 28 watt rating
and getting some great performance this
the xps is running at 3.4 gigahertz
right now
compared to about 2.9 on the macbook so
definitely high frequencies it's
starting to cut down just a little bit
here
and of course we have this in the high
performance mode the xps fans are
kicking out but now we're roughly at
about 80 degrees celsius
so it's starting to cool it down but
that's also because our wattage is at
19. so it looks like yes
dell is lowering wattage to keep this
running cool and quiet
on the other side though we're still
running at 99 degrees
celsius super hot we are getting some
power
throttling but not as much 18 watts
compared to 28.29 so apple doesn't care
and the fans are now spinning up louder
than xps's but we're definitely keeping
up performance we're near the end now
the macbook pro sounds not like a
hairdryer but getting close to there
it's definitely loud
whereas the dell is almost silent but
it's only running at 15 watts at 70
degrees celsius instead of
97. bam so the macbook actually beat
the dell xps in getting the test
done and wow so the xps scored
14.85 that's actually slightly slower
than
last time around and our macbook scored
16.76 now this will actually run closer
to 1900
if you run it unplugged because it
doesn't heat up as much
very odd and we've only found that with
this particular macbook pro
that's shocking how much dell is
limiting the wattage of the system
out of the box i don't know if that's
for battery life or for what and just to
show you guys
as far as windows performance lighting
it is set to best performance when are
plugged in
and so let's dig a little deeper uh i
went ahead and opened up dell powers
management
and going in to the thermal management
we have a setting here
for ultra performance so i'm going to
change it to that
let's run this again i hope this gets
better as far as performance because
this is really bad i'm going to unplug
the macbook pro
for our second run and let's see what
kind of difference that makes
and here's our results of the second run
our macbook pro
didn't really change that much compared
to the last run
even though we've had it over 1900 in
the past whereas the xps
it went up to 1753 so now beating out
the macbook pro and getting a good
improvement compared to before now it's
still interesting that
the wattage actually still went all the
way down to 15 watts towards the end of
the test
just didn't throttle as early on it did
run a little bit louder still quite a
bit
quieter than the macbook pro and overall
the mac
uh if you want the best performance
actually unplug it it's really weird
with the dell make sure you go and
change that setting
i'm gonna explore this further see if
there's any other limitations on this
system
for our full review so make sure you
guys are subscribed for that video
now let's talk about battery life and
it's going to get a little bit
interesting here
the previous dell xps with the same
display that got about five to six hours
of battery life which isn't great
compared to about eight to nine hours of
battery life on this
macbook pro now of course we do have the
new 11 gen cpus which that could help
we'll talk about that in our full review
as well but
if you're going to go for the xps and
you get the 1080p screen
that actually gets better battery life
than the macbook air at 9 to 10 hours
of real world use so if you want this
gorgeous 4k display
i would probably expect maybe five to
six or maybe with 11 gen
maybe possibly seven but we'll have to
see in the future
and now let's talk about prices the
retail price of the macbook pro is
eighteen hundred dollars
and the dell xps is actually 1700 it's a
hundred dollars less expensive and
that's with this
higher than 4k display that's also a
touch screen now of course with the xps
there's lots of different configurations
so i'm gonna have a few linked
down in the video description that i
would recommend there's a 1080p option
you guys can go and check out those
prices
and of course there's constantly sales
for example right now for the macbook
pro there is a fantastic sale probably
the best price i've seen
and you guys can check those prices out
at the time that you're watching this
video
now the ram and ssds match up here but
of course with the xps
that those upgrades are cheaper when
you're buying it out of the gate
and you can actually upgrade that m.2
ssd yourself so my suggestion would be
buy a lower end configuration for the
ssd and use our recommended
2 terabyte ssd upgrade that yourself
it's going to be
faster than what's in here it's less
expensive and you'll get 2 terabytes of
capacity i'll make sure to link that
down below as well
so what is my overall verdict well i
just have to say
wow i did not expect so many little
differences and changes
that are making the xps so incredible
the keyboard
is fantastic i don't want to say it yet
but it might just be better than the
macbook pros
awesome magic keyboard the trackpad is
probably the best windows track that we
we've used i keep saying out the dll xps
reviews but they keep making it even
better the screen of reflectivity i was
not expecting and
when we're looking at it more so it's
not as deep on the blacks but i think it
might actually be less reflective and
this was an issue with many dell xps so
that has been solved the graphics
performance is the best we've ever seen
you can actually do some gaming on this
laptop which we will be testing
out and the cpu performance for your
normal usage
single core performance is through the
roof multi-core performance is awesome
and then if we can get the wattage not
drop so fast
for people doing photo and video editing
with this great graphics
man it's gonna do an awesome job so this
thing is impressive
at this price point with the 4k
touchscreen and the
storage and ram this is going to make an
incredible machine for those of you guys
who don't mind having
windows instead of mac os the mac pro is
mac os
the trackpad is better the speakers are
better the display
it's sharp and it doesn't drain as much
battery so it's still a great option for
the price
it's it's a really tough choice i think
what i said before and i agree
even more now if you're somebody doesn't
mind windows
you're gonna have an excellent
experience with this laptop you're
getting a ton
of bang for the buck let me know your
guys thoughts
down in the comment section below which
one would you buy and why
make sure to click that circle above to
subscribe for our full review
and check out one of these other great
videos right over there
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
you